[APPLAUSE]
HELEN SCALES: Thank
you very much.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
So thank you for giving
up your lunch hour to come
and hear me talk about my book.
My name is Helen Scales.
I'm a marine biologist.
And just in case any
of you are wondering,
that is my real name.
Scales, fish,
marine biology, yes.
And this is my book, "Spirals
in Time, The Secret Life
and Curious Afterlife
of Sea Shells."
I want to tell you a little
bit about why I wrote the book
and tell you a few of the
stories that go into it.
Starting off, already the
title-- "Spirals in Time,
The Secret Life and Curious
Afterlife of Sea Shells"--
in the review I got
in "The Guardian"
newspaper a few months ago,
I made the mistake of reading
below the line on the website
version and looking at some
of the comments
people had written.
And one person felt necessary
to comment on the subtitle,
"The Secret Life and
Curious Afterlife"
was clearly a
clever, clever title
provided by the
publisher enforced
on this kind of
popular science books.
It's the sort of title
you have to have.
Luckily, somebody
else commented also.
It just kind of tells you
what the book's about.
That's fine.
But actually, it wasn't
my publisher's, it
was my mom who came up with
the title-- the subtitle.
And I'm really pleased she
did because it means she kind
of got what the book was about.
From me talking about it
for ages, and also making
her read bits of it
as it was going along.
She clearly kind of got what
it was I was trying to do,
even perhaps before
I really realized.
So yes, there's really two
things I'm doing in the book.
One is telling the story of
the lives of the shell makers.
The animals that
make sea shells.
We all know those beautiful
objects you find on a beach.
You might have picked
them up, taken them home.
But where do they come from?
How are they made?
What happens in the lives
of the creatures that
left these shells behind?
So I wanted to tell
partly the story
about the wonderful
creatures, the mollusks, that
makes these shells.
Mollusks are really one of the
most strange, smallest, tough,
ancient, and successful groups
of animals on the planet.
We're talking about
familiar creatures.
Mollusks range from slugs and
snails and squid and octopus.
And two slightly stranger
things you might not have heard
are things like argonauts and
sea butterflies and chitons,
and weird little things called
[INAUDIBLE] gastros that
live in bottom of the sea, and
frankly just look like worms,
but they are still mollusks.
And they are one of
the most diverse groups
of animals on the planet.
Really, they're only
beaten by the arthropods.
Another phylum.
These are phyla that
were talking about.
Kind of grouping them
in the animal kingdom.
And the arthropods
include all the insects.
So they definitely win in
terms of the largest number
of species within a phyla.
There's over a million
species of insects.
Alone, most of them are beetles
but mollusks come in, I think,
good second place, frankly.
And they are an
incredibly strange bunch
of animals that live all
sorts of different lives.
It's thought there could be
about 50 to 100,000 species
of mollusk alive today that
we've described already.
And we don't know for
sure, because there's
no-- up until now, there
hasn't been a central catalog
to list all the names of
all the mollusks that have
been described scientifically.
We're now doing that.
So hopefully we'll get
a bit more of a grasp
on just how diverse
these animals are.
But it's thought by some of the
leading thinkers and scientists
who work on mollusks
that actually there
could be more like
200,000 species, including
ones we haven't discovered yet.
Including creatures
like these guys.
So these are more micromollusks.
They were found in Papua
New Guinea just last summer.
They are all under 5
millimeters in size.
About the size of your
little fingernail.
And none of these have been
described scientifically yet.
They've just been found.
They were found during
an expedition lead
by a guy called Philip Bouchet
from the Natural History
in Paris.
And he basically spends his
life going around the world,
leading expeditions, trying
to find as many mollusks
as possible.
People do this kind of thing.
Scientists focus on a
group and really try
and figure out what's going on.
These were all found
around coral reefs.
And they're just, just
incredible creatures.
These are types of
mollusk, snails,
and clams that no
one's ever seen before.
A clam with pink tentacles
for goodness sake.
And transparent shells so you
can see the skin underneath
is brightly colored.
But these particular
animals, and plenty more
that they find on
these expeditions,
remain on a museum
shelf undescribed.
They're called orphan
species because we
lack the expertise to
actually have people sit down
and name individual species.
We just don't know about
this kind of diversity.
So there's all this hidden
side to the lives of mollusks.
That was partly what
I wanted to talk about
in the book was all the
things that we don't yet
know about this incredible
group of animals,
including the species
that we haven't yet found.
And Philip, I spoke to him.
And he's one of the people
who really thinks there could
be 200,000 species of mollusks.
And he should know.
He looking for them.
He's finding more and
more all the time.
Even if all he's really
doing is doing a head count.
This is something different.
We don't know what it is yet.
We don't know what
might contain.
We don't know how it lives.
What interesting things that
these animals might be doing.
And one of the things
I really amazed me when
I was writing the book--
right up until the point where
my published were like, no.
You have to stop now.
You cannot put any more
science into this book.
There's so many new discoveries
are coming out the mollusk
world, that pretty
much every week I'd
be like, oh, there's
another cool story I
want to put in the book.
Like the fact that limpets
have the toughest teeth
made out of the toughest
known biological material.
They've knocked spiders
silk off the perch.
And they figured that
actually because these
are the snails that clamp
themselves to rock and spend
their lives scraping the
rock with their teeth,
they've evolved this incredibly
strong material in their teeth.
So it was like, that
has to go in the book.
Somewhere, we have to get it in.
And then I think actually
just the last thing
I did manage to
get into the book,
the last story was about
how cone snails-- these
are poisonous sea snails
that live in the tropics.
They are notorious for having
incredibly diverse and complex
toxins that they use to hunt
all sorts of animals, including
fish.
And there are a few species
that if they sting a human,
they will actually kill them.
Bit of an overkill,
but there's reasons
why we think they're
such powerful hunters.
So that they can actually-- a
tiny snail that slowly slides
along the sea bed,
has the ability
to eat fast moving fish,
which is kind of incredible.
And a new discovery just
came out a few months
before the book came
out that they in fact,
use insulin as part
of their weaponry.
So that the only animal we
know that's kind of evolved
this hormone so that it
essentially knocks out
its prey by giving
it a dose of insulin
so that their blood sugar
levels drop, and they faint.
And they can then
eat these fish.
That's just really cool.
So there were lots of
incredible, cool, amazing, mind
blowing discoveries coming
out of the mollusk world.
And that was a really
big part of what
I wanted to do in the book
was to capture this excitement
of what we're discovering.
And the applications of a
lot of this, this science,
is exciting too.
The cone snail
venoms that have been
used to develop
medicines, that have been
used in biomedical research.
The fact that razor
clams- I don't
know if you've ever seen the
long, thin shell shells you
might see on a beach.
They burrow themselves
in the sand,
but they're much more
efficient to doing it
than just their muscles
and their shape,
and the strength of their
shell would suggest.
And researchers have figured
out that they actually
have this clever
technique of creating
little pools of quicksand
around them as they dig down.
And it's incredibly
efficiently way of burrowing.
And this could lead to the next
generation of underwater robots
that can fix things
to the sea bed.
Even undersea cables
for the internet.
They could be fixed down
by these robots inspired
by razor clams.
There's tons of cool
stuff about mollusks
that I was trying to
talk about in the book.
And what I wanted to capture too
was some of the big discoveries
and some of the big
questions that scientists
have thought about when it
comes to shells and mollusks
over the years.
And one of the big ones is
the shape of their shells.
How is it that shells are made?
They've got these-- many of
them are beautiful spirals.
I call my book
"Spirals in Time."
I guess because I wanted
to allure to the idea
that these things have been
around for a long time.
And spiraling around.
These calcium carbonate spirals
have been around for probably
for half a billion years.
We think mollusks first
evolved in the oceans
about 500 million years ago.
But how do they
make their shells?
And why are there so
many different shapes?
And in lots of great
thinkers have put their mind
to try and work out what's
the mathematics that lie
behind shells and shell making?
One of the simplest
parts of a shell,
of a mollusk's spiraling shell,
is the logarithmic spiral.
A spiral that expands
at a constant rate.
[INAUDIBLE] came up with
this idea of a log spiral.
And if you cut through a
chambered nautilus, which
is this shell here, you get
a pretty good approximation
to that logarithmic
spiral in two dimensions.
And if you look at lots
of different mollusks,
many of the gastropods with the
spiraling shells, the snails,
as well as these
the natutilises,
and various other,
the bivalves too,
clams and so on, they do still
have spirals in their shells.
We'll come to that.
What about into
three dimensions?
That was the next big
question that scientists
were thinking about.
Mathematicians and
philosophers wanted
to figure out how could you
make a three dimensional shell?
It's all very well the same.
You've got these two dimensions.
The log spiral is really
important actually,
because no matter how
big or small it is,
it's the same shape.
And that is a key
rule to making shells
is that if they're tiny
of if they're huge,
they will stay the same shape.
So mollusks keep their
shelves their whole life,
unlike crustaceans,
the crabs and lobsters
will shed their shells
and grow new ones.
Mollusks keep the same ones,
just growing bigger and bigger.
But they stay the shape,
even if they're tiny or huge.
But how about three dimensions?
So it was the turn
of the 20th century,
there was a guy called
Darcy Wentworth Thompson,
who wrote a book called
"On Growth and Form."
And he was really thinking
about shapes in nature.
And how can mathematics
describe the shapes
of a splash, or a deer's
antler, or indeed,
the shape of a three
dimensional spiraling shell?
And he came up with the
idea that perhaps you
create these 3D shells by
spinning a two dimensional
shape in three dimensions.
And so essentially
what he's looking at
is having a central axis around
which maybe a circle, a flat
circle spins around.
And it can either do
so in the same plane,
or it can drop down that axis.
The walls of the shell can
overlap each other or not.
And perhaps it would
only take three--
this is running away from me.
Stop it, stop it-- three
or four simple rules
to actually make all
the different shells
that you see in nature.
So he came up with this idea,
just a theoretical idea,
he couldn't test it.
All he had was paper and pencil.
Could you make all of
the sells we see nature
with three simple rules of this
single, circle spinning three
dimensions, how tall it
gets along that axis,
and how much those worlds
overlap each other?
These ideas were picked up 40
years later by a paleontologist
called David Raup
who did something
unusual for a paleontologist
certainly at the time.
He used a computer.
As he took these
equations from Thompson,
and he plugged them into a
mainframe IBM 1790 computer.
The sort of thing that
was at the time-- this
was in the '60s.
The '50s and '60s
was intended to be
used for designing aircraft
and nuclear reactors,
but I think he managed
to get some down time.
He was at Johns Hopkins
University in Maryland,
and he used this
computer to build shells.
And to see if these simple rules
that Thompson had come up with,
whether you really
could make all
the different shells that
you see in three dimensions.
And he did.
And the output he had
from his computer work
was all 2D plots,
which were then
realized by an artist
in three dimensions.
But we can now have
a look at a mock
up of what the output of his
model would have looked like.
And we're going to let that run.
I think it's incredibly
beautiful and mesmerizing.
So what we're doing here is
just changing these parameters,
the height, the expansion, the
rate at which the shell flares
ope as well.
And just by changing
these three parameters,
you do actually get incredible
diversity of shells emerging
from those simple rules.
The rest of your shells can be
explained through fairly simple
mathematics.
You get the clam form
a spiraling shell.
You wouldn't expect
that, but it pops up.
And what Raup did
was he created what's
come to be known as The
Museum of All Possible Shells.
And populated by these shells
created from these equations.
And what seemed to be all
these different, endless forms
that you see in nature.
But the really
surprising thing he found
was that the Museum
of All Possible Shells
actually isn't full
of real shells.
If you look at the
shell that have actually
evolved in the past
through fossils,
and through what's
alive today, there
are lots of parts of this space.
If you think about it as being
this actual space where there's
three parameters on the
next y and zed axis,
there are large parts of this
space that aren't occupied.
And those shells
haven't evolved.
And it's raised this
question about this
is a theory called
theoretical morphospace.
The possibilities of
what organisms could be.
What shapes they could be
and what they actually are.
And why there's a
difference between the two.
So evolution hasn't
taken mollusks and shells
to all the possibilities
that these simple rules could
lead to.
Some of these shells
just haven't existed.
Raup pointed out
that some of the ones
he made in his computer
wouldn't have worked.
There were clams
that wouldn't open.
There were some that
would just be flimsy,
and they wouldn't be competitive
out there in the wild ocean
and in places where
mollusks live.
But there were
plenty of shells that
seemed to be perfectly good.
And there seems no reason
why they haven't evolved.
And people expanded
this idea out now.
And we've built museums of
all possible fish and plants
and all different
types of organisms
that you can look
at their morphology
and see what potential
shapes they could be.
And then compare that
to what we actually see.
And again and again
you see this limit
of what evolution's created.
Of what evolution's thrown
up, and what potentially
could occur.
And discussions are going on.
There is this division
between some people who
think that ultimately yes, all
these shells could and would
evolve if the situation
arose that that shell would
be well adapted to a
particular condition.
And there are others who think
that actually, maybe, no.
Then that's the
evolution-- genetically
there isn't the material that
would ever evolve these shells.
It just would never happen.
And the discussions go on.
That's one of the
big questions I
look into on a bit more
detail in the book of how
shells evolve.
Why they're different shapes.
And why we don't actually
see all the potential shells
that mathematics suggest
could exist in the world.
So that's the life
part of the subtitle.
There's also the after life.
And this isn't the
bit of the book
where I talk about snail
ghosts or any kind of belief
in the after life.
It's really just my
desire to talk about how
humans have used shells.
So after the animals
inside that make
them have died and
long gone, and they've
left behind these
empty shells, we
do all sorts of
things with them.
And there's incredible,
long, history.
Pretty much to the
dawn of humanity
that people have seen
shells, they've found them,
and put them to
all sorts of uses.
Both practical and
incredibly deep
symbolism and
meaning in seashells.
I was really amazed researching
the book at just how broad
and how universal these
beliefs in shells are.
There are symbols
of sex and death
and birth and power
and money, and cultures
all over the world, and
even far, far from the ocean
have these incredibly
strong beliefs in shells.
So I wanted to tell
some of those stories.
I partly wanted to try and
reinstate some of the grandeur
and some of the wonder
and magnificence of shells
in human lives.
Because today, I think shells
have got more of a reputation
for being fairly-- they're
cheap, throw-away trinkets.
They're emblems of ocean that
we can buy from a seaside store,
or perhaps we find ourselves.
We don't really pay them
that much attention.
And people make
things like-- this
is the kind of thing people
use shells for these days--
Make things like
this, and also this.
I found this on sale on eBay.
She's got lovely,
lovely headdress on.
Oh dear, now it's
running away again.
What I wanted to
do was tell stories
of how people have used
shells in the past in ways
that are far more magnificent.
So this guy here is
about 7,000 years old.
I don't know why
this is running away.
Hang on a second.
I'm going to just do this a
different way so it stops--
stops going too quickly.
I wanted to tell stories of
how people have used shells,
not to make comedy frogs.
So this is a great
found in Bulgaria.
And about 7,000 years old.
They're called
the old Europeans.
Don't you want to know
why it's doing that?
AUDIENCE: I think you've
got auto advance on.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
HELEN SCALES: Excellent.
Stories of shells being
used in human lives.
There's this
incredibly rich history
of the beliefs and
symbolism of shells.
This chap is the leader
of the Varna community.
These guys lived in Europe
about 7,000 years ago.
Up until this point,
when this was discovered
in the 1970s, this grave in the
city of the dead in Bulgaria,
it was thought that
the old Europeans were
quite an egalitarian group,
and that they were mostly just
nomadic farmers.
There was no sign up until
that point of any elites
who were coming in
charge, and that society
was fairly even and equal.
And they found a
grave where a guy
covered in gold and with
all sorts of jewelry,
including some very
beautiful shell jewelry.
And that's why I wanted to talk
about this particular case.
Around this guy's
upper arm, you can
see on one side he's got
bangles, including a white one.
And that's made from a
shell called spondylitis.
It comes from a long
way from this part.
It doesn't come
from the Black Sea,
but from the Mediterranean.
And there was this
long distance trade
in these shells
called spondylitis
that were carved into
beautiful objects, all the way
across Europe up to Paris.
And often what
was done with them
is they were carved into
bangles that people wore.
And I think there's
even been studies
to show that some
of these bangles
were put on to people's arms
when they were children,
and then they grow into them,
and couldn't take them off
again.
This particular one though,
it was just really intriguing.
So it was carved
from this big shell.
They're called spiny oysters.
That's another name
for these shells.
In life, they're
covered in spines.
But cut them through
and they've got
this beautiful,
bright white shell.
And carved into a bangle,
broke it, and then
fixed with gold plates.
And that's what
this guy's wearing.
We don't know why they did that.
There's various
other remains that
seem to be deliberately broken
of these shells left in graves.
There's some significance
behind this particular shell.
It was always the same
species that was being used.
And then it just disappeared,
and they stopped being used.
It was about 6,000 years
ago, and that's it.
No more spondylitis.
There was a parallel trade
in spondylitis shells
in the Americas, with the
Aztecs and the Mayans.
They were using
spondylitis shells
for decorations and money.
They were carving
statuettes of humans,
giving them to
children, taking them
to the tops of the
highest mountains
and leaving them there,
as human sacrifices.
So there were all these
incredible, significant stories
about shells.
And so I tell some of
those stories in the book.
And hopefully try to reinstate
some of the sense of mystery
and wonder about
what shells are.
And I think one of
the reasons people
value them so much
is because they
come from this dark, deep
ocean where they're full
of sea monsters and
things we can't see.
But these beautiful
objects wash up on beaches.
And people have always
wondered where they come from
and how they're made, and
hold them in great meaning.
Oh.
Now I've broken it entirely.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hang on.
HELEN SCALES: See if we
can get some pictures back.
That's fine.
The beliefs and the symbolism
and mysteries of shells
haven't all just
died out in the past.
There's plenty of modern--
There are still
some modern stories
and modern of shells
filling that role
of some mysterious
objects surround
by some significant
beliefs and ideas.
And I thought of the story of
one of them in the modern world
today of this stuff
called sea silk.
Silk from the sea.
And lost of ancient stories
have been told about stuff
called sea silk, which
comes from a shell called
the noble pen shell, which
grows in the Mediterranean.
They can grow to
up to a meter tall.
They look like giant
muscles, just like a muscle
that you'd eat.
They stand really tall.
And this stuff called sea
silk comes from the threads
that they make to anchor
themselves to the sea bed.
If you've ever eaten muscles
or cooked them, blue muscles,
you would probably had to
debeard them and yank out
the fibers that they have.
Same stuff.
Only these shells have really
big ones because they're bigger
and they have to use
their byssus threads,
which I'll come back to--
to anchor themselves solidly
and so they don't
get sucked away.
Anyway, so there's lots of
stories told about sea silk,
also known as byssus.
There are stories told
of the ancient Egyptians
buried their
pharaohs and wrapped
in cloth made of sea silk.
Henry the Eighth had a picnic
with the King of France
with his men all dressed
in golden sea silk.
And the stories go on and on.
There's stories in
the Bible of sea silk.
And a lot of people
do still believe
that this has a very ancient
origin maybe thousands of years
ago.
And I went to Sardinia
to find and to meet
the lady who calls herself
the last maestro of sea silk.
She says she's the
only person left
in the world who knows
how to weave fabric
and threads from this fiber.
A lady called Chiara Vigo.
There was a story in the BBC a
couple of days ago about her.
You might have seen
it on the BBC website.
Check it out.
That gives one
side of the story,
which is interesting
about what she goes up to.
And she has a museum of
byssus, a byssus museum
in a tiny island of Sardinia
called Sant' Antioco.
What she does, she
practices weaving.
She shows people
how this is done.
And retells all these stories
about byssus and sea silk
going back into the Bible and
beyond a thousand years ago.
But as I was researching
and working on the book,
I met and spent a lot of
time with a few people who
actually study sea silk and look
at it the academic side of it.
And scholars have traced
records of sea silk
back in the literature
and back into the past,
and discover that there's a
big problem with this story
that sea silk is such
an ancient stuff.
And it really it comes
down to a spelling mistake
in the 15th century.
And a lot of talk
about seal silk
goes back to Aristotle's book
on the history of animals.
And he talks about pen shells.
And how they have these
fibers coming out of them
called byssus.
And therefore, sea silk
comes from pen shells,
and it's connected
to this word byssus.
But actually what
the truth of it is,
is that word byssus was
never connected to pen shells
when Aristotle originally
wrote those books.
It was a translation
much later that
mistranslated a word that
means deep and depth, the word
that leads is to things
like abyss and bathysphere.
And what he was
originally saying
was that these shells
grow in the deep water.
And that was that.
That's why he used
the word byssus.
And the translation came
along in Latin, later
on in the 15th century,
shifted an accent
from one word-- I
think it was actually
from the Greek from
one letter to another--
and changed it from meaning
deep to meaning fine cloth.
And from then on, byssus was
associated with fine cloth.
And there is a word
byssus that means
linens and cottons and
all sorts of fine fabrics,
but not specifically.
But once that
translation kicked in,
and it was a really popular
translation of that book
by Aristotle, everyone
thought that byssus whenever
it was mentioned, back
in all of the old texts,
refers to sea silk.
And it doesn't.
It just means fine cloth.
So unfortunately all
this talk about sea silk
being this ancient
stuff, it doesn't really
have any foundation.
But no one really is listening
to these scholars who
are saying have you actually
looked and seen that there
is this mistake and we we're
actually telling stories that
aren't true.
But that doesn't stop a
certain lady continuing to show
people this, and that's fine.
I went to see her.
And she was very pleasant,and
she showed me what she was
doing.
But when I was in
Sant' Antioco, I also
met-- OK, that's a
lump of raw byssus
before it's been processed.
As it's been pulled
off the shells
there are little bits
of sea shell in it.
And that previous
shot is a piece
of processed byssus and sea
silk before she weaves it.
I met these ladies who
also weave sea silk.
So Chiara is not the only one.
she tends to be the maestro.
But there are some other
people who still do it.
So these lovely ladies
showed me the same process.
How they carved the fibers,
how they spin them and then
use them to weave
embroideries like this.
One of the problems is that
pen shells are now protected.
They're a protected species
because, for various reasons,
they're not doing very well.
They live in sea
grass beds which
is suffering from things
like climate change,
and habitat destruction.
So they've been protected.
And you're not allowed
to actually take them.
It's illegal to
take these shells
or to harm them in any way.
Chiara claims that she has found
a way of sustainably harvesting
sea silk from shells by
taking them up and snipping
their threads, and
then putting them back.
The problem is that
she's so surrounded
in secrecy in what she
does, that no one is
allowed to go with her
while she's doing this.
And so I can't comment as to
whether she's actually doing it
sustainably or if
she's up to something
else, because she absolutely
refused for me to go with her
and see what she was up to.
The other ladies--
this is the picture
of these two these guys.
Jessapina and Acentina Pez
were very open and said to me
we can't get a hold
of anymore fibers.
We can't do this new anymore.
They had a little
collection of it
that their grandmother
had given them,
and they use it to
show people like me who
want to see how it's done.
Mostly they just use
other fibers these days
and carry on with their
traditional weavings,
but not with sea silk.
And occasionally a fisherman
will find a dead shell
and give it to them, and
they have a bit more to use.
But they're like, it's
a thing of the past.
We want to remember
how it's done,
but we can't pretend
that we can still
do it because these shells
just aren't available.
I felt like when I was
reporting on this story,
this is not what I
was expecting at all.
I was just expected to
tell this simple story
of this strange old fiber that's
been here since the Bible.
And found I was getting sucked
into this stranger story than I
unexpected of things not being
quite as the should seem.
So, it was really fun.
So a question I often get
asked by people, mostly kids,
but then they always
ask the best questions
when I'm talking about
shells and mollusks
and my book is what's
my favorite shell
and what's my favorite mollusk?
So I tell them that's
really hard question.
You do that there might
be 200,000 species.
But OK, if you make
me, I will tell you
that my favorite
is the argonaut.
I even have it on my tee shirt.
That's how cool it is.
And there's a couple
of reasons why
I do genuinely think that
argonauts are brilliant,
brilliant mollusks.
Firstly, while they are the
only octopus that have shells.
So octopus of a mollusk
that generally have
evolved life without a shell.
They have a soft life.
They have evolved
other mechanisms
to survive and to
incredibly well
without having an
external shell.
But argonauts still have shells.
You can just about make out.
They're also called
paper nautiluses.
They're not related to
the chambered nautilus,
but they look a
little bit like him.
And they have this papery
shell, and a little octopus
lives inside.
And they're very
beautiful creatures.
I've never seen one myself.
They live in the open ocean and
they're really hard to find.
You often really just
find the shells washed up,
but no living creature inside.
And for a long time
the big question
was there were these sort
of gentlemanly arguments
and debates among scientists
in the, technically
Victorian times, about
the truth behind argonauts
and whether or not they
make their own shells
or whether they steal them
from some other animal
that we haven't yet discovered.
This was the likes of Richard
Owen, the guy who set up
the Natural History Museum.
He was really keen to
figure out whether argonauts
were shell makers or basically
pirates that stole shells
from other creatures.
And there were just
brilliant stories
told in all sorts of-- I
think Aristotle told stories
about this, about argonauts.
I think he started
it all off actually
by claiming to have
seen argonauts using
their shells as little boats.
So I haven't got
one to show you,
but they are quite
hollow and light.
And you can imagine that
they would float along
the surface of the sea.
And he told stories of seeing
these little octopus sitting
inside in their
shells and sticking
two of their tentacles, which
one of them you can see here.
They do spread out
into this wide membrane
which we'll come back to.
But he [INAUDIBLE] put
them in the air as sails,
and they caught the breeze.
They drifted around
in their little boats.
Or other scientist claim
to have seen argonauts
using their arms to row
themselves along, again,
on the surface of the sea.
With their little boats.
And the story get told and told.
If you read "20,000 Under
the Sea," by Jules Verne,
he tells the story about how
Professor Arronax at one point
pops up on to the nautilus.
Ha, ha.
There's the nautilus.
There's the name again.
Actually, it's quite sweet.
They see a raft of
argonauts drifting past.
It seems to go for
about five minutes.
Yeah, with their little
ears which are their sails,
supposedly drifting along.
It's his butler at one
point, he points out--
I don't know if you know
the story of "20,000
Leagues Under the Sea,"
how it's Captain Nemo who's
this crazy mariner who
kidnaps the scientist
and takes him around the
world in the nautilus,
which is his submarine.
This is some scientific truth.
A lot of the stuff
that he writes about
is what was the science at the
time we knew about that Jules
Verne-- it was really
a marine biology book.
But with a story,
which was quite nice.
And Professor Arronax, the
marine biologist's assistant,
actually says, well,
why didn't Captain Nemo
call his ship The Argonaut?
Because argonauts, the octopus
can actually come all the way
out of the shell,
unlike a nautilus,
which is like a snail.
You can take it out.
It would immediately not
be very well if you tried
to pull a snail out of a shell.
But the octopus can
leave their shells,
but they just choose not to.
And Captain Nemo was the same.
He could leave his is submarine,
but he chooses not to.
He lives forever
beneath the waves.
Kind of an exile from humanity.
So I thought that
was quite nice.
There was a point
in the book where
I was like you
should have called it
the Argonaut, not the Nautilus.
So this debate went on about
do argonauts make their shells,
or do they steal them?
And the other
reason why I really
wanted to tell the
story of argonauts
and why they're brilliant
is because of this lady
who you finally cracked
this question of the truth
about how argonauts.
Her name was Jeanne
Villepreux-Power.
And she was French and
married a Sicilian.
She went and lived in
Sicily as a lady of leisure.
She started off life as a poor--
in a little village in France,
but ended up meeting this
guy and getting married.
And spent the rest of
her life as a scientist.
Basically as a lady
of leisure, she
decided that she wanted to go
out and just explore the world.
She explores Sicily.
She did lot of studies of
the animals of the island.
She sounds a bit like a
latter day Gerald Durrell.
She brought things to live
in the house with her.
There were pine
martens running around.
But one of the things
she did, and she actually
isn't very well
remembered for, and why
I wanted to write
about her story,
is that she pioneered some
incredible marine biological
studies.
And invented an aquarium
tank for research.
And she built this thing,
which was just made of wood.
It was an open box
with wooden slats
let sea water come through.
And she would anchor it
at the edge of the sea.
And she would take
argonauts that fisherman
would catch for her, and
she would occasionally
catch herself, and
she'd place them
in these observation chambers.
And she conducted some really
quite elaborate experiments
to figure out do
they make shells,
or do they borrow them
from something else?
Or do they parasitize
another animal?
And I give the details of
the experiments in the book.
And it's a pretty
brilliant ideas.
Some of them are a bit cruel.
You have to do things
like break argonaut shells
and see if they can fix them.
Take their shells away.
And she slowly built
up this picture
that really did convincingly
show that argonauts,
yes, they do make
their own shells.
And in fact, it's
the females that do.
The males were just
nowhere to be seen.
But it was always
the females she found
were making the these shells.
And in fact, the
membrane that you
see on the outside of the shell,
that's what makes the shell.
It's really different from
to other mollusks, which
have this thing called a mantle,
which covers all of their body.
And that's what makes the shell.
Whereas they have a modify
at the end of two tentacles.
And it looks silvery
when you see them alive.
And they can fix up patches
in their shell if it's broken.
And they also make
the shell initially.
They only ever make one shell,
like the rest of the mollusks.
So if they're parted from their
shell, they don't survive.
Which I guess is why they
always hang on to them.
So she started having
ideas, Villepreux-Power
did have ideas about
where were the males,
but she didn't quite
get to the bottom of it.
The females make these shells.
They lay their eggs
inside the shells
and use them as a brood chamber.
But where are the males?
And it wasn't too much
later it was discovered
that the males are tiny,
tiny small and basically kind
of parasitize the female.
Then they have one tentacle
with a packet of sperm
on the end, which
they lob at her.
And it sticks to her body.
And she can collect
a few of them
and put them inside her
shell and carry them around
until she's ready to
fertilize her eggs.
So the males have a
rather different problem
in life than the female.
And still things
we're finding out.
New things about argonauts,
recently, one guy in Australia
found some live ones and
discovered that they actually
use their chamber, their
shells as a buoyancy aid,
but like chambered
nautilus they have
air inside their shells, which
they use to keep them floating
under water.
So it's a bit easier
for them to swim.
And argonauts do
a similar thing.
If he emptied all the
air out of their shells,
they all would swim straight
back to the surface,
gulping some air
into their shell,
and then swim back
down until they
were neutrally buoyant at that
the depth they wanted to live.
So it reduces their cost
of swimming by having
a bubble of air inside them.
It's like an underwater
blimp, which is very cool.
And leads me to my final thing
I wanted to tell you about,
which takes me back to
the title of the book.
And also I wanted to tell you
a little bit about the art
work, which I absolutely love.
And really just so pleased with
the way the book has come out
and how it looks.
And it will comes down to
this picture of an argonaut.
It was around the time I was
writing the argonaut chapter
that my publisher at
Bloomsbury said that I really
had to decide what I what I
was going to call the book,
because we had come up with
another title, which early
on we decided we didn't like.
I was going to call it, "Snails,
Tears, and Thunderstones."
And then everyone said, I don't
know what thunderstones are,
and what's this thing
about snail's tears?
I can explain
nature if you want.
But anyway, we decided
that was no good.
But I'm so obsessed
with argonauts when
I was writing this chapter.
And with all of the great
stuff that she discovered,
and all the silly stories.
All I could see were argonauts.
That was my view in life.
So I wanted to call the book
"Flight of the Argonauts."
Especially with this
discovery of how they use air
to help them swim under water.
So I'm now hunting around online
for pictures of argonauts,
and I found this one.
And it's by an illustrator
called Aaron Jean Gregory.
And have a look at his websites.
Not only did he sell tee
shirts with these on them,
which was really
cool, it turns out
that he's in a band
called Giant Squid.
He lives in San Francisco,
and we got in touch.
And he'd just been
on holiday to one
of the islands
off of California,
and he found an argonaut
shell on the beach.
We have to have this guy.
He's a marine
biologist by training,
was retrained, has just
retraining as a fine artist.
So he is as geeky as I am
about all the marine creatures.
I was like, we have to have him
to do the front cover art work.
Because we were
also looking for who
we wanted to work with on
that, as well as the title
of the book at this time.
So we got in touch
with him, and I'm
really pleased that
he agreed immediately
to work with us,
which is fantastic.
And I don't think he quite knew
what he was letting himself in
for, because we were still
undecided about the title.
And I was still pushing for
"Flight of the Argonauts."
So we were like, go and
do us some argonauts.
So he does some sketches.
I'm going to show you some of
the sketches that he sent us.
As unseen before.
Anyway, apart from
being my publisher.
So first of all, he gave us
some tentacly argonauty ones.
And I think they're great.
And I was really just so keen to
have "Flight of the Argonauts,"
and argonauts on
the front cover.
But no.
We decided that no one
would think that-- it
wasn't a book about argonauts.
Just a bit of it.
So we had to [INAUDIBLE].
Think of a different title.
And it was literally coming
down to the last minute of like,
can I just have
another day to decide
what the title is going to be?
And I kept on coming up with
ideas that weren't working.
And then went to a
holiday to Devon.
And spent a few days mucking
around on the seashore.
And finding shells and
having a nice time.
And then "Spirals in
Time" just popped up,
and I thought that'll do.
And everyone else
seemed to like it.
So we stuck with
"Spirals in Time."
And that actually
meant for the cover
that we then had a whole free
reign of what we could put
on the front cover of the book.
I should say that I
really appreciated
having a chance to be involved
in designing the front cover.
Authors don't always
have that opportunity.
For my first book, I was
just told, here's your cover.
Whereas Bloomsbury were
keen to have me involved.
It's been really fun to be
a part of the way it looks,
as well as the words inside.
So I told Aaron--
so the two things
I wanted to have
on the front cover
were lots of different
species of mollusks.
I wanted to try and capture
this idea of them being
this incredibly diverse group.
And I also want
them to be alive.
One thing again, that I really
want to do with the book
is to show people
that shells aren't
just these boring dead things
that sit around doing nothing.
They come from these
incredible living creatures
that live extraordinary lives.
So I wanted living, diverse
mollusks all over the cover.
So the first sketch he
came up with was this.
[INAUDIBLE] just make that out.
There were loads and
loads of mollusks.
But Jim Martin [INAUDIBLE]
was like, nope.
Too many mollusks.
Cut it down.
Too confusing.
How about a spiral of mollusks?
The title is "Spiral in Time,"
so we could have a spiral.
Brilliant idea!
So we said go do us a spiral.
So Aaron did us a couple
of spiral sketches.
Do you want it down page, or do
you want it coming out at you?
Of course, I wanted
it coming out at me.
He then said that's really pale.
But we basically said,
yeah, a big spiral,
going across both covers.
He pencil sketched.
This, for me, was
really interesting,
because I don't know how art is
done these days, but apparently
what he did was he painted these
in with ink and paint brush,
by hand.
And then he colored
it in on a computer.
So he used a tablet to do all
the coloring in, afterwards.
After scanning in the inks.
And then he came up
with some color options.
And we decided
which one we wanted.
And ultimately, that was what
we went for, and I just love it.
I think it's brilliant.
Some of the other
things he did--
he did this illustration at
the beginning of each chapter.
So I just wanted
to show you those.
I would say, OK, the
chapter about cone snails,
we want a nice, active
cone snail catching a fish.
And then he inked
those in as well.
The chapter about
sea butterflies,
these beautiful sea snails,
that microscopic animals
that fly through the open ocean.
A whole chapter about those.
So he did us a beautiful
image of sea butterflies.
And then ammonites.
Actually, that's the
chapter with the argonauts.
And I talk also about the
ancient extinct mollusks.
And this is parpuzosia,
the biggest ammonite that
grew to three meters across.
And the little shark there
is to give you scale.
So just some beautiful images.
And then finally, I'm really
pleased that the book-- if you
get the hard back, and if you
do grab a copy, the end plates.
I wanted this for my first
book, but they said no.
But I really want to
have beautiful sails
on the beginning and the end.
So I said, we wanted
wentletrap snails
because they've got these
incredible complex shells.
So Aaron did this little sketch.
And then that's
what it looks like.
So if you do have a-- grab
a copy of the hard back,
you have snails, about life
size, falling over the front
and back cover.
So there you go.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]